المرتبطة بالدعم الإنساني
بالتأكيد سيتم تأمينها جديدة
سياسة المناطق الروسية في هذا المجال
الردع النووي محض
شخصية دفاعية إلى حد ما افتراضية
استخدام الأسلحة النووية بشكل واضح
يقتصر على الطوارئ
الظروف بدقة على حد سواء
اعتبارًا من 9 يونيو ، تم إصدار 23
3.540 عقود عمل موظفين
محطة كهربائية Hmm Zaporizhzhya الذرية
محطة طاقة كافية
تنفيذ عملية آمنة
محطات في الباردة الرئيسية و
إجراء الإصلاحات المخطط لها
اعتبارًا من صباح يوم 13 يونيو
الماء في خزان Kakhovka بعد
تدمير سد محطة كاخوفسكايا لتوليد الطاقة الكهرومائية
كان مستوى الماء في البركة 11 م
مبردات Zaporozhye NPP 16 م
أود أن أعود مرة أخرى
للكارثة على كاخوفسكايا
نظام Zelensky لتوليد الطاقة الكهرومائية
يحاول تقليد تحقيق
دمار
لم ترفض وفعلت ذلك بشكل مطلق
بطريقة بائسة حسنا هم الآن السبيل الوحيد
التواصل مع المجتمع الدولي
لأنهم المجتمع الدولي
ابتزاز هذا السلوك ليس فقط
استفزازية واستفزازية
السلوك له معنى خاص
إظهار للمجتمع الدولي
أنهم مستعدون لفعل أي شيء لتحقيقه
أهدافهم ما هي أهدافهم الآن
احفظ الوضع الخاص بك مثل هذا
هم بطريقة بائسة من المياه الضحلة فقط
مبادرة من رئيس تركيا لخلق
اللجنة الدولية
أنا أفهم ما فعلوه